look at us I feel like we could go to
this Premiere together as uh go with him
as a Morticia actually yeah I appreciate
everyone wearing the black there's a lot
of amazing looks tonight how did you
settle on this for tonight
I felt like if I was gonna if I was
gonna go um
wear black like everyone else I probably
should make a deal out of it I think she
would appreciate the veil it felt uh I
don't know I put it on and I just knew
that this is probably what I should do
you know when we talk about you
transforming into this role I act as if
I don't care if people dislike me
[Music]
deep down
I actually enjoy it
I mean you play the cello your fencing
in it what was training like for those
things
it was it was a lot I I started cello
and fencing a couple months before we
started production and then I I
continued throughout the the eight
months of shooting in Romania and I
would have lessons a couple times a week
so I would do the 12 14 hour work day
and then I would have
cello and fencing at the end of my day
things like that yeah
[Music]
a little faster I like the travel
incognito come on let's roll
yeah how excited are you to share
Wednesday with the rest of the world
right now I feel pretty good yeah yeah
I'm gonna do something really dope with
this yeah
[Music]